Great. You're listening to radio man,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio.
W. Y. C. O. N. N. P. R. Hey everyone. Jad here for this week's podcast.
I wanted to play you a piece from one of my favorite producers.
His name is Ben Rubin and uh, he's, he's kind of hard to describe.
He's sort of an audio artists, sort of a documentary producers,
sort of a visual artist if anyone's out there,
has been to the New York Times building, the new one, he and his partner,
Mark Hanson did this sculpture,
that crazy moving sculpture that is in the lobby. Any case,
this is one of my favorite pieces from him.
It's called open outcry and I don't want to tell you too much about it except
that it's about, uh, commodities trading. You know,
like when you picture the trading floor with hundreds of people screaming out
the prices of commodities, there's a name for that.
It's called the open outcry trading system and all those screaming people sort
of in that roiling pit determine on this sort of emergent level,
the price of oil on the price of an ounce of gold.
So Ben decided to do a piece about this and most of what you're gonna hear in
this is actual documentary sound he recorded on the trading floor of the New
York Mercantile Exchange. There's also going to be a female voice,
sort of an ethereal female voice that was recorded in the studio obviously,
which is actually her singing the real price of commodities taken.
You know, the raw data taken from one day,
I think in September of 2002 though I'm not sure about that day in any case.
Here it is. Open outcry from Ben Ribbon on a on Radiolab
[inaudible]
orange juice down in 94 49 zero zero BD one 50 cotton
cotton,
45 90 orange juice down 94 55
go down two 14 silver up 44 78
[inaudible] 30 48 zero zero
cotton down 45 85 silver 44 78
crude oil, 30 53 two silver, silver
[inaudible] nine zero zero
[inaudible] [inaudible]
sometimes I see to people,
didn't you hear rebidding and I know if they say I didn't hear you.
I know they're not telling me the truth because people always hear my voice.
It's, it's unique and it's a strong voice too. If I'm selling October's,
you know,
you don't say you say oc and you don't say the full hand and just say like AUC
at 10 so I just yell out Pocket 10
oh it's 70 bit by by play five. So 25 ox, 75 bed at 78 I tell you today,
seven blocks, seven beds,
(258) 415-5500
yeah. Listen to one person at a time.
You're hearing everybody speak at the same time.
It's like going to a symphony and hearing every piece of the orchestra,
but yet hearing the music at the same time. And in the midst of that,
you may observe, for instance,
a broker that you've traded with for years.
You notice face looks like when he's laughing.
You know what his face looks like when he's upset about something at home and
suddenly he's got a nervous look. You can tell when someone is bluffing,
when somebody is not bluffing and this,
these are all skills that are learned over time.
It's really an internal gut feeling.
And as far as just seeing the expression on somebody's face,
the way that somebody's breathing,
the way that somebody is leaning on someone else.
I always knew when the guy behind me had a real order, cause when he had a big,
big order,
he used to take my shoulder and shove it to the ground trying to hold it.
I'm so fat to fit these two,
so 50 these are toe 10 to bed,
five to 10 bed choirs too.
Big Novi and a half, five and a half.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] Silva
Orange Juice now,
huh?
Gasoline, natural gas.
[inaudible]
crude oil. Natural gas.
Well, I've been in a ring 32 years. How do I sound? You know,
uh, the open outcry system, which is probably with me,
some people may look as an antiquated system.
It's probably the most sophisticated timely system, uh,
that's in existence today.
If you believe in, if you believe in it, in a marketplace,
this is as pure form as it gets.
If everybody's buying, it's going to be tougher to buy, right? Simple as that.
Just because you want to sell it at $29 and 55 cents and you're offering 29,
55 the guy next to you could be selling it.
The guy in front of you could be selling the guy behind.
You could be selling it and you might not have sold anything.
Volatility makes money. War creates turmoil.
Turmoil creates opportunity. Yeah.
I'm not suggesting that people want terrible outcomes,
but I am suggesting that a lot of people depend on them.
Yeah. It's all 50 October, October,
[inaudible] hundred these house days used to half, man. Jeez,
my 25 ds, one bed. So why aren't these two beds,
temperature players, a lot of money flying around moment to moment, you know,
and um, there's a classic story actually. It's about my father.
And there was a time in silver when, uh, he got into an argument,
somebody and he had their neck down against the rail and a guy looked at him,
he says, Marty, even though that you know, you're chairman of the floor,
come in when I have to find you 500 bucks for this. It's,
he looks at the guy, he puts, he, he keeps one hand on the guy's neck,
takes the other hand in his pocket, throws down 1000 bucks.
It says double it cause I'm going to finish him off.
Know two minutes later they're out having a cup of coffee together.
J 23
[inaudible] 23 [inaudible]
[inaudible] aluminum mockup,
orange juice.
They're going at school down
[inaudible] [inaudible]
they were members in good standing that had been on the trading floor the day
before September 11th, that we would never see again.
And I think people were very, very aware of their absence. In fact,
the first trading day for at least the first trading day,
some of their positions in the pit were sort of silhouetted by their,
the outline of the footprints and people wouldn't step into those spots.
[inaudible]
that's an open outcry by Ben Reuben as you can probably tell.
That piece is written right after nine 11,
he was asked to commemorate the reopening of part of the world financial center.
Most of it was still in rooms, but this one part,
the winter garden was opening back up.
And so he was asked to make a sound piece to install in the winter garden.
And this is a space with, um,
with a grid of palm trees in the middle of very, very high domed ceiling.
And what he did was he installed speakers underneath the trees and that's where
the voices of the traders came from. But, uh,
way up top on the ceiling, he had speakers which played the voice of that,
uh, female ticker.
So it's as if the traders are on the floor and high up above them.
Almost ethereally is the price of the commodities. Kind of a neat idea.
Except you said in the, in the space, the sound was totally terrible.
No one could hear anything,
so he was happy as are we to have it be a radio piece in case you can learn more
about Ben, uh, at his website, ear studio.com. That's
www.yourstudio.com. You can also check out our website, radiolab.org.
We are supported by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
I'm Jad Abumrad. Thank you for listening.